talking of frightening animals though
South Africa yes we did a bit yeah this
is Doctor Who in South Africa they see
but now you had a proper terrifying
encounter the sort of thing Kevin would
not like this
yes so I'll try and speak slowly so that
everyone so we were filming in South
Africa and unbeknownst to me the some of
the South African crew had been filming
what is known as a sac spider crawling
up and down out of this tree
so the SAC spiders in the tree they're
filming it filming each other I've got
footage saying this is terrifying look
how terrifying that is no one told me
I've run out of the building
everything's a secret so I'll tell you
what building and run out of the
building into the wilderness as this
sucks spider just crawled down you get
down me absolutely breaks it and cannot
repeat what I said costume was off and
our first ad the first assistant
director was English pretty casual they
just picked it up and chucked it as all
the South African and then we found out
I could have died Wow
didn't didn't Google a sack spider by is
he's like a really big board a big ball
it was a sack explaining you it's got
poisonous balls keep going it's making
the story a bit different so but yeah it
was horrific
I was so brave there's so many things so
many things wrong with that whole thing
first of all I can I can break it down
okay
everybody that was taping it in the
beginning we're white that's fascinating
oh my god when it lands on you and you
go oh my god beep beep beep and you're
you're getting it all for you
people are still taping they were white
it's it's it's so clear than the guy
that picked it up chugged it he was
white Oh problem with this thing nobody
immediately thought we shouldn't tape it
this could be something nobody was at a
it's just part of a big balls I don't
you get out of here and pack up we can
shoot today
[Applause]
[Music]
you